hello everyone i would like to
um thank the organizers first for their
invitation to present
um at this exciting symposium
i'll be discussing today b cells and
human solid tumors
and primarily the question i always get
asked in
in my research program is what
they're important for and and why we
should
understand them better in solid tumors
so the way that we go about studying b
cells in human tumors and
in my research lab is by looking at a
multi-level approach
of the immune transcriptome of those
cells by single cell rna-seq
um doing microscale functional assays to
look at the function
potential functions of the b cells we do
a lot of high level flow cytometry
both 15 to 18 parameters and then
spectral
cytometry which is more computationally
based that allows us to measure 35
markers
and we also do a lot of locational
studies especially because b cells are
located within
tertiary lymphoid structures which i'll
talk more about here in a few minutes
and we can pair that with some new
technologies technologies via nanostring
um digital spatial profiler um so
if you have any questions please feel
free to email me
since this is a recorded event i'm
available at this email below
so the first thing i want to start with
is just why we should care about the
immune system
um in patients that have cancer so i
initially started
my studies in lung cancer patients and
you can see here that this is a scan
from a patient that was um pre-treatment
pre-pd one treatment
two months post and four months post and
for those of you that aren't used to
looking at these scans
you have red arrows that point out the
nodules
in these patient lungs and after two
months of pd-1 treatment the nodules
expanded but
it was biopsied and determined that
these were immune cells
um and and then at four months they had
gone away
and so this is really great and it was
really important to me as a graduate
student because i was actually screening
these antibodies
as a grad student before they were
chosen to go into the clinical trials
and now they are standard of care
and and while this has been really
effective um
there's there still is a lot of work to
be done particularly there's a lot of
patients that don't respond to
immunotherapies that are currently given
by standard of care
um and in clinical trials and there's
other immune cells in there
other than t cells and a lot of the
immunotherapies have been very t cell
centric
um and and thirdly b cells which is the
focus of today's talk
um are very abundant in the tumor
microenvironment in fact they're the
second most abundant
lymphocyte and most tmes so
um i was given the opportunity um in
back in january to write the news and
views for three papers
um that came out that really highlighted
the importance of b-cells not only in
solid tumors but in
immunotherapy and it was shown that
having b cells and having territorial
influence structures
actually correlated with better
prognosis
and also better response to
immunotherapy
in melanoma sarcoma and renal cell
carcinoma so that was really encouraging
and it's not just an immunotherapy as
i've already alluded to
but also in um just solid tumors in
general if we track lymphocyte
infiltration
there's been shown time and time again
that cd4 t cells and cd8 cells
correlate with better prognosis of these
patients and again these are lung cancer
patients
but what was really nice about this
paper that is actually old now
is um that they also showed b cells and
um
they actually showed that b cells were
correlated with better prognosis in
these lung cancer patients and that's
not only in whole tissue sections but
it's also been shown in tmas
um from several groups and this is from
um kurt shelford's group that does a lot
of imaging and work on
um immune cells within multi-spectral
imaging techniques
and again it's not just lung i've showed
you some examples in lung
in the last two slides but it's also it
had a neck colorectal breast ovarian
cervical and other solid tumors that
i've already mentioned such as melanoma
and renal cell
so they're important and they correlate
with survival and immune response but
what could they potentially be doing
um so this slide is meant to set the
stage for potential functions of b cells
and um here on the left-hand side these
are mouse
studies that really contribute to the
pro tumor side of things
that's because a lot of mouse models are
not um long-term enough or immunogenic
enough to have
formation of tertiary lymphoid
structures and that's where a lot of b
cells reside
actually are in these structures so a
lot of these studies in mouse models and
there are a few in humans have indicated
that b
cells actually have inhibitory receptors
secrete suppressive cytokines
um um generate non-specific antibodies
and that we
that um results in um myeloid cell
recruitment that then
um dampens the immune response within
the tumor micro environment and then in
a lot of autoimmune studies they
actually educate t-reg cells however in
humans
um it's more than the case that they
have an anti-tumor function and i
demonstrated that with some of the
survival data
and the immunotherapeutic response that
i showed you
just a minute ago but um some of the
potential functions that have also been
shown are antigen presentation or
education of t cells by b cells
tumor reactive antibody production which
is of course the first thing we think of
um adcc via nk cell mediated killing
um territory lymphoid structure
formation which i've already alluded to
and also direct tumor lysis and so
really in our lab what we're trying to
do is understand b cell function
both in solid tumors but also we have um
some projects where we're looking at
prenatal neoplasia or pre-malignancy to
understand their role earlier on
and all of these studies will then help
us to determine how to effectively
target b cells
and immunotherapies for cancer patients
so to start off and give you a picture
in lung cancer
and i'm going to start off in lung
cancer and move into head and neck and
then come back to lung cancer at the end
these are two vectra stains of
and this is actually back when perk and
elmer still own vectra
um when these were done so this is a
while ago but what was very clear from
this initial
these initial studies is that there's
v-cell infiltrate in both of these
patients which is outlined in red by
cd20
but in this patient up above it's much
less and the organization of this
structure
looks to be a lot less defined than this
one down at the bottom where you see a
clear
b cell zone here and you had c cd4 t
cells predominantly adjacent to it
this is a true um kind of tertiary
lymphoid structure
um and less of a lymphoid aggregate and
it's actually a bit more mature than
this structure up here
and i'll talk a little bit more about
that later and um territory lymphoid
structures sit in the strumming pockets
so while
you can see tumor around here that's
where they reside um
and um that's where most of the b cells
then reside so if we do counts and we
compare
um b cells in the stroma here in blue
versus those in the tumor you can see a
very large difference
in that number and there's more in the
stroma and there's other cell types in
the two compartments but it's
definitely more pronoun most pronounced
that the b cells are highly
in the stromal compartments versus the
tumor we've also validated this by flow
cytometry where we've looked at
lung cancer specimens with tumor and
tumor adjacent tissue
and we've looked at total numbers of all
different immune cells and we've done a
ratio
of the total numbers from tumor to tumor
adjacent tissue what's quite striking is
what you can see is that b
cells in these patient tissues are
sometimes increased
20 to 80 fold whereas cd4 and cd8 t
cells are increased but not to the same
degree so it's not that the t
cells aren't there and they're not
important it's just that there's a
higher
amount or influx of t cells um at the
tumor
further we've expanded into other tumor
types starting to look at not only b
cells but the
amount of plasma cells that are present
um
and one thing that's quite clear is that
um
the there's more b cells and head and
neck and lung cancer than plasma cells
and when we get into some other indices
such as ovarian
or ascites as a result of ovarian cancer
or even metastatic lung effusions
we're starting to see that it's not
necessarily as big of a difference
between those
two cell types so while that's not the
focus of today's talk that in and of
itself is interesting because these are
obviously
b cells have to be a b cell before it
becomes a plasma cell so there might be
something happening with the trajectory
and differentiation of the b cells in
these different tumor microenvironments
so the way that i like to frame
the questions is thinking about you know
what is key to
our understanding of b cells and tls and
human cancer so within the um
news and views article that was written
i came up with a schematic
um to kind of illustrate immature tls
versus maturity
tls and what that might do to downstream
function
um in in the papers in um in january
um in nature they actually indicated
that having more of an immature tls
indicated lower t cell activity and
having a more mature tls where you see a
very nice defined
b cell center with c4 t cells around it
would correlate with
higher t cell activity and that might be
due to the fact that
functions such as antigen presentation
and tumor anti-tumor antibody production
is increased um and maybe when it's
immature there's more contact of the b
cell with the tumor and so therefore
there's more inhibition of the b cell or
just the b cell becoming inhibitory
itself
and so from that um these are some of
the key questions we're trying to attack
in the lab
one is thinking about the heterogeneity
of b-cells um
in tls and cancer and just really trying
to understand
what that heterogeneity is so we know
how to better target them
the second is thinking about how having
a tls might influence b cell function
which i've kind of explained here with
this less schematic
and the third is um thinking about how
to induce tls in cancer patients which
is something we'll um
come back to uh later on in the talk
so to kind of get to the first point
thinking about
function of b cells and and the
heterogeneous function of b cells
there was a paper published from my
postdoc studies in cancer immunology
research in 2017
that um was done in lung cancer patients
again and what we did is we established
an antigen presentation assay that we
still use in the lab now
um and um we looked at the ability of
the b cell to educate c4 t cells
especially given the fact that they are
in such close proximity in these
tertiary lymphoid structures
and so what you can see here is we
purify the b cells and t cells and we
put them back in the co
culture and even amounts and then we
look at t cell proliferation as a
readout
and the way this works is you can either
add no lysate in and just look at the
endogenous response
or you can add in different lysates
because b cells can pick up protein and
process it very quickly
and it can present it on mhc class 2 and
then educate the cd4 t-cell
and so what we see here without any
lysate in is that there's very clearly
three patients here
and every patient has a a dot in a
different shape
there's three patients here in purple
that the t cells respond right away
whereas the patients here in green and
blue there is no response
but what happens as we add in different
lysates we see that some of these
patients in green
start to respond and the different
conditions are ebv lysate which
is a control because most people are
exposed to ebv and there will be a t
cell response as a result
hypoligus tumor lysate which is where we
see the biggest response in these
patients in green
and a full-length cancer testes antigen
that has been shown to
have significant t cell responses in
lung cancer patients the h1b
so we see some responses in all these
green patients with all conditions
and then you can see the patients in
blue they just they just don't respond
so this was very much key to thinking
about the heterogeneity
and you can go on to read more about
what we we found in these lung cancer
patients but some key things that we've
thought about since then is
in this paper we really divided b cells
and activated and non-activated and
that's not really fair there's a lot of
heterogeneity and i'll speak to that
here um in the next few minutes but when
we did that and we just looked at
activation versus not activation
we saw that at the end of the co-culture
the cd4 t-cell phenotype changed so when
the b cells were more activated
you got more of a th1 interfering
gamma-producing cd4-t cell
but when the b cells were not activated
you got more of a t-reg
non-interfering gamma-producing box p3
positive cell
so that led us to start thinking about
other t-cell phenotypes and the other
t-cell phenotype that i want to
introduce here that's very important in
the tumor microenvironment particularly
in these tertiary lymphoid structures
our t follicular helper cells
and so we wanted to think about whether
or not b cells maintain tfh or
and we know that they interacted with
them in normal lymphoid tissues but how
does this happen in the tumor
microenvironment
we also wanted to think about comparing
b cells to other myeloid cells
so all other um cd11c positive myeloid
cells that potentially present antigen
how do b cells compare in the tumor
microenvironment and to just show a
snapshot of that in lung cancer patients
what you're looking at here
is a readout of cxcr5 which is a marker
for tfh
as well as interferon gamma which is a
marker for a th one as i already
indicated
and these are t cells that are extracted
and cultured by themselves
from the tumor of lung cancer patients
and you can see that there's cxcr5 tfh
cells but not a lot of interfering gamma
production which is not surprising
when we add in all other myeloid cells
um not b cells but
cd11c positive apcs we see cxcr5
maintained but
very little interferon gamma production
but when we spike the b cells in
um and we do that co-culture with b
cells and t cells alone
we see interference gamma production
increase
in cxcr5 maintained so this was really
key to us thinking about further
experiments down the road and really
cross
comparing myeloid cells and b cells in
the tumor microenvironment but also
looking at the readout of the t
cell which i'll talk a little bit about
the former um toward the end of the talk
again
and one last piece of data that was
really striking is we went back and
looked at some of the patients that
actually responded in the fact that the
t cells responded
and these patients did um clinically
better as well
so all these patients in purple and
green did better because they probably
have a more optimal immune micro
environment
um it's probably not just b cells but um
they also had a better cd4 t cell
response
when they were co-cultured with the b
cells and what was clear is if you look
at all of this brown staining those are
islands of b-cells that's ct-20 staining
and those are territory lymphoid
structures so there's more tls
in these patients when there's better
antigen presentation
so that gives a snapshot and some views
into looking at
um you know function and linking it to
um
the b cell function to the b cell
phenotype and then to the subsequent t
cell response
and that's all well and good but this is
um this is just the tip of the iceberg
and really
what we wanted to do is we wanted to
really get into
the different types of b cells that
could be in the tumor micro environment
and how these different tumor
microenvironments could influence b
cells
and so that's why at the time that i
came to pitt i was still moving forward
these lung cancer studies
um but i also was starting to work on
head and neck cancer
and so i'm going to switch over to that
now because i think it's a good time to
talk about why we use head and neck
cancer
and show some of those data before we we
talk about lung cancer again
and so head and neck cancer actually is
a good tumor type to study b cells and
that's already been established in the
literature
for multiple reasons first of all it has
two ideologies and there are some
differences
um within these ideologies like for
example you can have people that are
hpv-positive and have carcinogen
carcinogens that drive the disease but
for our purposes we
bend the patients into hpv positive and
hpv negative virally driven versus
carcinoid
carcinogenic carcinogen and driven
and that's the hpv negative and so in
the literature what's been shown is if
you look at the inter-tumor
immune infiltrate you see um t
cells and macrophages in both hpv
positive and negative
but you can see a very large influx of b
cells in hpv positive
further in a very large study where they
looked at survival they looked at hpv
positive versus hpv negative patients
and hpv positive patients that had
high infiltrate of immune cells had
mostly b cells here and that's in the
in the actual paper if you dig into the
paper and you can also see this trend
with hpv negative but to a lesser degree
when there's a high infiltrate
so this was pretty convincing that b
cells were this was a good model to look
at b cells and to look at them and
virally induce cancer versus not
and so um because of that increase in
the tumors we wanted to look at
transcriptional and locational
differences in those b cells so the
first thing we did is we embarked on a
large single cell rna-seq study that was
actually
um published in immunity in january from
our group
um the leader of that paper is tony
sillow a very talented post-doc
in the dignali lab that i co-mentor and
so um daario vignali and
bob ferris are co-senior authors on this
manuscript with me
it was a very large undertaking um
and we did um single cell by 10x i
probably don't have to introduce this to
the group but 10x allows you to
basically have barcoded gel beads that
you then flow through with immune cells
or any solid choice
in this case we did cd45 positive cells
that were isolated and that were viable
and it's a drop seek method so for every
one bead you see a cell and you can see
this in real time in this video
and um we then generate and collect
all of the um pooled um single cells
or all the barcoded single cells and
then we do library prep and sequencing
and then we can do this downstream
application of looking at cell
population
identification um and um
via a tisny or a umap whatever your
choice is
and then we can link that to where those
cells come from
the different tissue types and the
different cell types that are abundant
so what was um what was pretty clear
from the paper um was
and you can read about this as well now
is that there was a very large data set
we had quite a few hpv negative
and um less hpv positive but that's not
surprising given the incidence
um and we also had five healthy donor
tonsil from sleep apnea patients so they
did not have cancer
so they were baseline lymphoid tissues
for a comparison
which is really important for b cells
and then six healthy donor pdmc
so we had quite a few cells we analyzed
and you can see here two islands of b
cells that pop out that are quite
distinct and that's what i'll be
focusing on
for the rest of the talk however you can
pull this paper offline and look at all
the different cell types that are listed
here because
tony did a really excellent job on the
work up of all the different cell types
and so um basically what you can see
here then
is the different islands of cells and
what tony did was he actually ranked
them
as to ones that were the most
transcriptionally distinct between hpv
positive and hpv negative
and so what you see here is a bar graph
showing cells that are less similar
versus more similar when you go from
left to right
in hpv positive versus hpv negative and
the take home here is that b
cells are one of the most
transcriptionally distinct cells
in the microenvironment when you look at
hpv positive versus hpv negative
and i'll talk about this more here in a
minute what's also interesting is that
cd4 and cd8 t-regs are obviously in both
etiologies but they're not as
transcriptionally distinct as b
cells monocytes um or monocyte lineage
rather
and um t conventional c4s and what's
interesting about that collectively is
that these three
populations here are actually what are
in tls structures most predominantly
so what we did then after seeing this is
we actually took the b cells out and
segregated them bioinformatically and
then looked at the different clusters
that um came out from that bioinformatic
analysis
and so what you can see here are 11
distinct clusters when we just look at
the b
cells and this disney's showing that all
the different clusters the middle tis me
here
showing the different tissues that those
clusters are coming from
and then this compiled bar graph is
showing all 11 clusters and then the
ratios basically of where they're coming
from so
for example dark green or hpv positive
um till
and dark blue is hvb negative two and so
to make a long story short because this
is a very detailed slide
is that um there were canonical clusters
or canonical subtypes of diesels that we
could identify so clusters one through
four were germinal center b cells
clusters five was plasma cells six and
nine were naive and cluster seven were
switched memory b cells
and not only can we see these different
clusters you can see a um
an enhancement in hpv positive versus
apd negative
for one type of b cell versus another in
particular in hpv positive they were
very enriched for clusters one through
four
as you can see here and for hpv negative
they were
enriched for clusters five and seven
which are plasma cells and switch memory
cells
so this shows pretty definitively that
there's very distinct differences
in the b cell heterogeneity when you're
in two different um
micro environments one viral and one not
viral
um and so what we wanted to do since we
we had a lot of cells for our single
cell but we wanted to really
add more breadth to this and give some
survival analysis
to it and have more patients involved we
then went back to the tcga
and we looked at survival of the
patients in the tcga so to set that
context i just want to show you
where the um where the the different
cells lie
within this trajectory so the naive b
cell has to come
in to um the germinal center and there's
two zones dark zone and light zone but i
won't be talking about that today
for the sake of time but basically we
did analyze this further
and in the germinal center they toggle
back between dark zone and light zone
and this is where they interact with tfh
cells
or t follicular helper cells and then
eventually they should get kicked out
and become a memory b cell or a plasma
cell so this is a very
general um schematic of the b cell
heterogeneity
and where it all comes into play for the
trajectory which we'll come back to
a little bit later as well and so when
we looked at this survival
we saw that b-cells in general trended
with better survival
germinal center b-cells also indicated
better survival
when you had more of them memory as well
and plasma cells trended with worse
survival
and i won't be talking about any of
these other these other two populations
today although we're following up on
both of them
i'm going to focus in on the germinal
center piece because germinal center b
cells have been very well described in
lymphoid tissues
um they are known to be paramount for a
very optimal
maximal moral response in um in those on
lymphoid tissues and in individuals in
general
so we really wanted to understand how
germinal center b cells might be the
same or different
in these two different etiologies
um the last thing to mention on this
slide is tfh signatures were also
correlated with increased survival um in
in these patients and that goes well
with the germinal center
journal center survival graph given this
schematic here on the left
so the next thing we wanted to do is we
wanted to validate our transcriptomics
with protein and this is pretty
important because
you you have a lot of data you get from
single cell but you always want to
validate by protein because there may be
things
that might not be as clear um in the
transcriptomics or you might not see as
big of differences
or there might be dropouts so we wanted
to validate um
the two subtypes germinal center b cells
in particular
um and look at that quantification so we
did this by
high dimensional flow cytometry so these
disney plots here are actually from flow
cytometry data
from hpv positive and negative till that
were run at the same time and what you
can see is we can
isolate out the same types of um
um cells that you saw in the in the tis
knees from single cell before
and what's really important to note here
is that you have germinal center b cells
that pop out very highly and hpv
positive and less so in hvac negative
which is what we saw
um and we also see um naive b cells
increase in hpv positive which was also
the case
um in the previous slide um compared to
hpv negative
um and what we're also we also see are
some additional populations pop
out that we didn't necessarily see in
the single cell in particular activated
pre-germinal center b cells
which are important for the progression
to this germinal center
piece and what we did then was we
quantified by
traditional flow cytometry dating and
saw that in hpv positive
we had more dermal center b cells than
an hpv negative
um we also looked at plasma cells
because they don't fall out of this
disney because they're not in the night
the cd19 positive 20 positive double
gate they're going to be outside of that
um because they're usually cd20 pim and
what we saw there was that
there was a trend toward morning to be
negative similar to what we saw in
transcriptomics but it didn't reach
statistical significance
so while this is great we also wanted to
look at location it's pretty important
as i mentioned earlier because b
cells reside in these tertiary lymphoid
structures so we did this first by just
single plex ihc
looking at cd20 and comparing to a
positive control which is a healthy
donor tonsil
and so what you can see here is that um
there's a lot of cd20 staining
everything is lighting up brown and you
can see even some of these
german center structures even from far
from a very
um zoomed out view here and if you were
to ask a pathologist to score a normal
tonsil for
tls they would say there's over 500 in a
tonsil pathologically
so we wanted to then look in um hbu
positive and hpv negative tissue
sections
and so we looked first in tonsils that
had tumors because you get them more in
hpv positive in the oropharynx but they
can occur in hpv-negative
what's very striking here is you can see
a large reduction in the brown staining
for cd20
in both sections but more so in hpv
negative so these are both tonsils and
this tonsil is basically devoid of
b-cell infiltrate there is some
tls here you can see but it's very low
and there's more in hpv positive but not
as much of the positive control
so when there's tumor there is um
um there's going to be some re-altering
and some
alterations rather to this micro
environment but we still have this
maintenance of v cells in hpv positive
compared to hpv negative
and we also see that in non anonymity
tissue such as the tongue and this is
illustrated here
in two sections in time with the same
sort of staining
so we had our pathologist anjalu
actually quantify this and
count tls structures by cd20 staining
because pathologically they're able to
do that it's not the best marker and
i'll talk a little bit about that later
but we can use it for an initial count
and so what we saw
is that in the tumor um we saw increase
of
tls and hpv positive compared to hpv
negative however in the non-tumor tissue
they were
even in the two indices so this again
goes back to the point of b cells
fluxing to the tumor and there being
more structures closer to the tumor in
that perituberal space and even in the
tumor
and and and trying to understand that
importance further
these cells are often within tls despite
their tls
despite their hpv status so similar to
lung cancer like i showed you earlier
the b cells are mostly in tls structures
there are some that get into the tumor
bed but they tend to gravitate toward
these structures
so then what we did is we started to
look by multiplex
amino fluorescence so this is again
vectra and this was done by
a very talented um graduate student in
the lab sally anker who
actually um does a lot of the training
for our vector staining and
and has become a real whiz with this
technology and um what we did was we
care
we compared a healthy donor tonsil which
you can see very nicely
a nice b cell center with punctated
macrophage infiltration and cd4 t cell
around around it this is a really nice
germinal center um in a healthy donor
tonsil and so when we look at hpv
positive tumors such as the base of
tongue we can see something similar
maybe not
as large as this one but we still see
those same sort of
infrastructure however you can see that
the heterogeneity varies because we can
see in another hpv positive tumor in the
tongue it looks as though these are
starting to become more organized but
it's not very distinct like
these two here and then lastly in hpv
negative we can get
like a nice germinal center like we can
in other
hpv positive tumors or healthy donor
tonsils but again this even looks
slightly different than these two
um by size and even the cell infiltrate
is not as robust here as it is here
so this is just to point out that this
heterogeneity
is something that we're continuously
working on so it's not a straightforward
answer it's a really big large
research effort in the lab to really
look at heterogeneity and multiple tumor
types and try to
define this better in a more objective
way um because we know
it can be similar to healthy donor like
lymphoid tissue but it
isn't always and so we're really trying
to understand this better
but for the purposes of this study we
really just wanted to
rate journal center-like versus
non-journal center-like tls
so something that's a germinal center
like tls is going to be this because it
looks very like much like this but
there's probably some things about it
that aren't exactly the same
and so we don't want to call it just a
germinal center that's why we say german
center-like
um and so what we did is we had the
pathologist go
back and count then not just tls
but germinal center-like versus
non-general center-like tls
just for simplicity purposes to start
and so
this is showing a snapshot of that even
by cd20 staining so if you ask a
pathologist
from a cd20 staining to identify
germinal center versus a non-germinal
center like tls
they can do that by looking at the cd20
saini and the formation of this journal
center as you can see very clearly here
and not only did we look at that
distinction but we looked
intra-tumorally
peritomorally where these are mostly
found these tls structures
and in the non-tumor area because we had
whole slide sections that we could do
that where
and so that's what this graph is showing
here so germinal center-like tls are
higher in hpv positive here in
blue both intra-tumorally and
peritomorally compared to hpv-negative
but again the non-tumor are similar and
this is really striking because um
we are able to classify the dermal
center like tls but also because we're
starting to see um these journal center
like tls
in the actual tumor which is not
something that has been shown in other
um um um other studies to date
so um so this is important and and
something that we need to be thinking
about when
they're on the peritoneal space versus
within the tumor
the other thing we wanted to do is we
wanted to correlate this back to
survival so the cohort that we picked um
had a great
num a really great follow-up and this is
follow-up in days actually
um and we looked at german center-like
versus non-general center-like and what
we saw is that if you're hpv-positive
and have more germinal center like tls
you um you actually do better than if
you don't have them
and but it's also the case in hpv
negative so a lot of people will say oh
well that's just because hpv positive
patients do better
yes they do but the hpv negative
patients also have a similar trend when
they have germinal center like tls they
just have less
um and then lastly bringing it back to
kind of the other cell types in there we
also wanted to kind of
start to think about you know tfh cells
and the other cells that are involved in
this process so we had the pathologist
also count cxcr5 expression
in histological sections and hpv
positive versus a2 negative and it was
very clear
that in hvb positive there's much more
cxtr5 expression than an hpv negative
so this again um basically validates
some of our transcriptomic studies and
our
follow-up flow cytometry showing that
you know we have more b
cells we have now more germinal
center-like b cells and now the tfh are
also following suit which is what we
would expect
so the question from here really says
well why are tls so
heterogeneous i keep coming back to this
because it's a question that we're still
trying to tackle and will be for a while
i think so it's possible that the
markers for tls are incomplete maybe
there's some markers that are
underappreciated
and that's what i'll talk about next um
we've also thought about
distinct cell cell neighborhoods that
might influence this or unique tmes that
might influence this so i've already
shown you the difference of hpv positive
and negative
but i'll also show you some differences
in lung cancer patients which is also
even more different in comparison
um to head and neck cancer so to come at
this first question of incomplete tls
markers
one thing that we went back and looked
at um via um the scitec which again
um this was um captained by um ayanna
ruffin in the lab
um she is a graduate student focused on
b cells and tls
and what we can look at now is the same
sort of disney plots from the flow
cytometry data
but it basically gives you feature plots
showing high and low expression of
different markers for b cells
and so the one that popped out was this
cluster here this is the germinal center
cluster and it's marked by cd38
expression
um and the semaphore a is very very
bright and so some of 4a
has been shown to mark human germinal
center of b cells and that's been shown
in non-tumor tissue
and what we really wanted to understand
is how this might be different in tumor
tissue
so what we did was we then quantified um
this expression then on the tumor tissue
and so what we saw both by mfi and
percent that in head and neck cancer
till
germinal center b cells and pre-dermal
center b cells that i described earlier
have higher expression of some 4a by
both mfi and percent
than other populations within that same
tumor microenvironment
but also compared to healthy donor
tonsil so as i mentioned it's already
been described that cement 4a marks
these b cells
um that are germinal center b cells but
maybe it's a better marker
in the tumor tissue and it seems that
it's enhanced in the tumor tissue
so we think that this marker could have
a lot to do with the formation of tl tls
and getting to a more germinal center
like
tls in the end the other way we looked
at this was by
ihc singleplex ihc and what we saw
was we we compared bcl6 which is a
hallmark
germinal center marker and what you can
see here is bcl6 is quite nicely
staining this healthy donor tonsil and
this is a germinal center but as you
look at some of these
hpv positive and negative tumors these
germinal center-like areas which are
canonically and pathologically
tls if you ask the pathologist they'll
say yeah that's a tls
they're not staining as nicely for bcl6
as the healthy donor tonsil
and even in some hpv positive tumors
when you have like a pre-germinal center
like tls
and what's happening here is there's a
cd20 aggregate here
that then we looked at bcl6 on bcl 160
is almost non-existent
however when you look at some of 4a
what's really interesting is you see it
both on the healthy donor tonsil
you see it to an increased degree on the
hpv positive tumor
and then in the hpv negative tumor you
see it but mostly on the macrophages
which are these larger
cells here pathologically and then you
also see it in the pre-general center
so this is really interesting that it's
increased and it almost seems like it's
stating a bit better than bcl6 so we're
formally following up on this and trying
to understand it better
but what i can tell you is that sema 4a
in our single cell analysis
also marks gc b cells really really
distinctly
and um when we do pseudo time analysis
it marks the progression of a naive b
cell to a
through a pre-germinal state to a
germinal center b cell so it very much
supports some of these protein analyses
that we're looking at
um i mentioned sell cell neighborhoods
so one other thing that we did with
these germinal center-like and
non-journalism-like tls is we looked at
the cell cell neighborhoods that come
out of having a germinal center versus a
non-general center
like tls and what's striking is that the
germinal center like tls the
interactions are what you would expect
there's a lot of tumor tumor
interactions because these are
this is very tightly um compacted
together
but um and then a lot of b-cell
interactions a lot of interactions
t-conventional cells but when this goes
away the primary interaction of non-gc
like tls
are t regs and ce8s and so this this
suggests the more pro
tumor environment occurring
um we also looked as i mentioned at the
viral proteins are thinking about the
viral proteins and the different tumor
microenvironments
so one thing that we're following up on
now and and we have some preliminary
data on
is that the virus seems to um
have a different effect on the types of
b-cell infiltrate that's there
and the reason we've come to that
conclusion is we were first looking at
this
um graph that i showed you earlier um
but it's simplified just showing hp
positive and negative for total tls
numbers
in the tumor and you can see that it is
increasing hpv positive but there's a
large spread
here of the tls numbers so we got to
thinking well maybe
there's differences up here versus down
here and maybe some of these patients
look more like these patients
which are hpv-negative so we
collaborated with um jim pippis who
looks at um viral oncogenesis and he um
in his lab mined the tcga and looked at
um
viral protein distribution for um e67
alone or additional viral proteins
so you can see here about 26 of the
patients are e67 alone
whereas 47 percent of patients also have
other viral proteins predominantly e4
and e5 were the two that they found
and when they looked at the gene sets
that came out when you had these two
additional viral proteins
it was a very strong leukocyte signature
and actually very strong for
germinal centers so cd19 cd27 cd4
cxcr5 cxcr4 all ones that i've mentioned
or are new that actually mark b cells or
t cells and
therefore dermal center markers and if
you're looking at one of these graphs
these are patients that have e4e5 in
addition to e67
these are patients that have e67 alone
and these are patients that are hpv
negative so when you compare these two
they look more similar
than the patients that have additional
viral proteins so now we have a
follow-up going on between ayanna ruffin
and another student in the lab shan lee
um trying to understand the impact of
these viral proteins on
b cell and tls function
the other thing i should note before
moving on to the last piece is that we
cross compared this with our single cell
data i showed you earlier and a lot of
these
genes that popped out as overlapping are
ones that we would predict
and um tls and our important anti-tumor
b cell function and t cell function so
that was very encouraging
so to finish off the talk i just want to
talk a little bit about our
lung cancer efforts um now i talked a
little bit about at the beginning but
that was branching from my postdoc into
my
um my faculty position um i want to come
back to this
this slide where we're thinking about
the key questions and i've talked some
about the heterogeneity and
really emphasized that and we've talked
some about the function and i'll do that
again a little bit at the end
but i think one thing that we need to
think about if we're trying to induce
tls
and actually maybe one thing is several
things is we have to look at other solid
tumors
so that's why we look at different
indices and i'll talk a little bit about
lung hair at the end
we need to think more about spatial
bioinformatics because while the single
cell
of um single cell rna sequence single
cell suspensions gives us information
we don't get the spatial information so
we're captaining and looking at some of
that
we want to think about lung cancer
progression so what happens as
a patient progresses the lung cancer and
also matching markers with function so
not only understanding the heterogeneity
of the b cells and the heterogeneity of
the function
when there's a tls versus a knot but how
do we match keep markers with function
and then lastly interrogating non-immune
cells so i just want to touch on a
couple of these i won't touch on all of
them they're all things we're thinking
of but i just want to
touch on a few so what the first thing i
want to show is just how different the
spatial distribution of b
cells of tlsr and lung cancer are
non-small cell and cancer tumors and
this is
work captained by a student in the lab
mia loop who's working on lung cancer
related studies
this is the same basic amino phenotyping
panel i showed you earlier but it's
showing very
vast differences in the tls structures
across the board
so we actually have patients that have
no tls structures and in lung cancer the
incidence is lower than in head and neck
cancer so that's not surprising
we have type 2 which we're calling now
that are distant to the tumor
and are more um um associated with the
bronchus
and then we have type three and four
that are peritoneal and
that look more like non-gc like and gc
like and that's just based off of
the infiltrate that's there and seeing
this nice kind of formation of this
dense td20 ring starting although it is
not as advanced or mature as what you
see in head what you saw in head and
neck cancer
so again there might be um a pre pre
journal center and then a pre-journalist
center and then a dermal center so we're
we're trying to
we're trying to work this out so one
thing that will help with this is
thinking about bioinformatically
and spatially how we can put these
things together and identify tls
heterogeneity
and um one way we're doing that and
we're doing it several ways but one way
i wanted to share with you is by using
the nanostring dsp
which we actually have available at pit
and um
it's actually in my core that i run so
um we
we can segregate the slide by tumor
normal adjacent and distant adjacent and
this is a lung cancer tissue
and um this is um pancake staining is in
green
and then you can see um cd45 is all the
pink and so you can
carve out ranges of interest that are
territory lymphoid structures in these
different areas and then cross compare
similarities or differences of those
structures
and so i want to give kudos to the
bioinformatics team that's capturing
this sunny and raj
and then the wet lab is mike and shelly
within
on the core and so um so what happens
after we look at this is we get heat
maps that can come together and this is
a really
detailed slide but the point of this is
not for you to understand every single
gene on here
but to look at the comparisons of tumor
tumor border
distal adjacent or normal adjacent and
you can see here um
vast differences in the um heat map
and what's really clear is that the
tumor border you have this group of
genes that look to be a little bit more
homogeneous
at the tumor border for tls's and each
one of these is a region of interest
and so you can see like kind of a group
of clustering genes whereas in the tumor
they're
very very different from each other and
in the normal adjacent you're seeing
clustering so it's as if
you move further away from the tumor
into the distance that you're seeing
less you're seeing more heterogeneity as
you get closer to the tumor and less as
you move further away
of course we need to interrogate this
further and look at the different
markers that are here and what that
might mean and we need to do more
patient tissues
but this is just one example of what
we're doing to kind of understand this
spatially
for both protein analysis and mrna
analysis
the other thing we're doing which is a
very large endeavor is we're looking at
lung cancer progression we've
assembled very fantastic cohorts of
normal smoker
lungs normal non-smoker lungs copd lungs
lung cancer overt lung cancer bone mets
and pleural effusions
and this is by active collaboration with
all of these individuals listed here
and we can look in pre-malignancy
primary cancer and metastasis
and understand the progression and so
what i'm going to show you today is just
in this early stage in tissue sections
what we're seeing
differences in normal lungs into copd
patients
and so what you can see here is that the
non-smoker
and this is a more sophisticated panel
to really look at b
cell and tls structures because we have
cxcr5 smooth muscle actin
igd for naive b cells and pnad for high
endothelial venules in addition to cd20
and cd4
so you can see non-smokers really have
random infiltrate and not really a lot
of tls
what's interesting in smokers is that
you can see that there are structures
forming but they're mainly b cells and
they're igg negative so they're mainly
memory
is is what we're concluding here for now
and then in copd you start to see this
appearance of agvs or high endothelial
venules and p
with p and a d staining as you can see
here in the zoomed in view
and you can see more naive b cells being
recruited which makes sense because as i
mentioned earlier naive b cells have to
get in
in order to um in order to be in a in a
structure and then get educated
in a german center and then proceed on
to memory or
memory or night or excuse me memory or
plasma cell
so this is really encouraging and so
what we're doing now is we're
actually building up the numbers and
quantifying this in several
patients to understand what it looks
like across the board
um the last thing that we're doing to
kind of link to the last point which is
function with the
actual types of b cells or key markers
on b cells
is we're using malignant pleural
effusions and it's not perfect because
it's not a solid tumor but what the
malignant polar fusion allows is a lot
of cells that come out of that effusion
and a high and a lot of them are highly
infiltrated by c cells as a result
and we can get sequential draws and we
have some nice controls both
benign by histologic histology or by
heart failure patients that have
um you know these um effusions that are
drawn but it's not due to cancer
and so what you can see here is that you
see an increase in the b
cell frequency um and the red line
indicates what it is in normal healthy
donor blood 10
and you can see an increase as we go
across the board here
and so this allows us to look at b cell
rich and b cell poor but also to get
enough b
cells out to conduct the same functional
to conduct two functional assays on the
same pool of b cells which i think is
really powerful and something we can't
do as readily and solid tumors because
of
cell numbers despite our ability to use
really low cell numbers we still
have to get a sense of what we're
looking for before we do those assays so
this allows us to kind of
understand that better so what mia did
um for this project is she actually did
the same antigen presentation essay that
i showed you earlier
but um in this case she not only did b
cells but she also looked at the same
myeloid cells
our c11c positive myeloid cells from the
same patient
and so what you can see here is there's
a color coding at the bottom where
there's b cells that didn't present
antigen in red it didn't matter if you
co-cultured them
gave them co-stimulation gave them an
external um
ebv lysate um it didn't happen
but what happened with the blue and
yellow is that
you have um the baseline here with just
the t and b cells together when you give
co-stimulation it goes up and then for
some patients it goes up even more with
ebb lysate
and then we showed that this was
specific by blocking with a pan mhc
class 2 antibody and then the antigen
presentation goes down
for the most part just one patient where
it looks like it's more nonspecific
um or there's some specificity but
there's some non-specific
kind of response um and and what also
what we also did here back to the point
from earlier is we directly compared
um you know the differences between the
b cells and the myeloid cells
so it's not the myeloid antigen
presentation is not shown here for
simplicity's sake but if we look at the
ratio
and look at the total proliferation for
b cells versus
b cell education versus myeloid cell
education we see that here in blue
these are the patients where they had
better cd4 t cell proliferation as a
readout with the b
cells and this is where um the myeloid
cells did
better or the b cells were equivalent so
we're seeing these differences
in the function compared to other
myeloid cells
further what what this study allowed is
we can now start to
link some of the key markers we would
think be involved with antigen
presentation
with proliferation of the cd4 t cell or
the readout of the assay so sema4a is in
there based off what i told you earlier
cd69 for tissue resident cd83 for
light zone um germinal center b cells
t40 and hladr in general because they're
required for anagen
proper antigen presentation and you can
see as those increase
here then proliferation also increases
and and that's pretty encouraging and
then lastly
we actually were able to pair the assays
um for antigen presentation and antibody
secretion and
i haven't really talked about antibody
secretion at all during this talk but it
is something we're actively pursuing and
we're trying to look at the amount of
antibody and the specificity of the
antibodies
um but what we did in this assay is we
linked proliferation with antibody
secretion and so what you can see
clearly here is that
patients that had um some patients here
that did really well with
um antigen presentation and had a really
nice there was a nice cd4 t cell
response as a result
made very little antibody and then that
inverses for other patients
some patients are still non-functional
for both and some patients are what what
we're calling multifunctional
so what we can do with disney um versus
the spectral cytometry is we can then
start to
put these into pots of cells that then
we can look at the different markers
that are
governing these different um and
understand how we can link
some of these markers up here with
antibody function versus antigen
presentation for example
now this is a little bit limited because
we're only looking at two functions and
i mentioned earlier that there's a lot
of functions
but we will continue to expand upon this
so with that i'm going to end and um all
the summary
here is things that i've said throughout
the talk so i'm not going to spend time
on it because i'm very close to my time
limit
i do want to emphasize that there's
still a lot that's unknown i think we've
made a lot of
progress understanding the b cells and
solid tumors but there's a lot of things
to do
and probably more appropriate these are
some of our future directions that i've
kind of mentioned as i've gone along
um but um we're really trying to think
about the complete tme
we are developing physiologically
relevant mouse models so we can back
translate um some of our studies into a
phys
into a model that makes sense um and
we're really um looking at
a lot of antibody studies as well i just
um they were not ready
to share today
um lastly i want to thank the team i
want to thank my lab and i highlighted
people as i went
they're all listed here i want to
highlight um darya big nali and his
fantastic group we work very closely on
a lot of t-cell related projects but
he's been very supportive of the b-cell
projects and
has um and people in his group have
really helped out tremendously
the lung cancer program had a neck
cancer program
um all of the other collaborators at um
the helmand cancer center
um my funding and obviously patients and
families for donating
um this is the group this is admittedly
an old picture and needs updated so we
will do that
soon um because this is a a
compilation of both mcnally and bruno
labs um
but one thing i want to highlight is i
really love the team i work with and i
think they're very talented and
we um do a lot of great science i think
but we also celebrate together so this
is all of us at my wedding
last year i'm actually coming up on my
one year anniversary
um and we had a great time so um
normally i would take questions but
because this is recorded
i will um stop here and if um anybody
has any questions please feel free to
reach out
thank you so much for this opportunity